Yeah,
we have to be clear.
The world has never been better than it
is right now.
Thanks mostly to globalization.
There are less and less wars.
Global poverty is falling markedly and
it's quality of life is generally
improved,
is obviously not happening in a uniform
way across all countries.
Burdened globally,
everything is improving.
Many western countries have decided to
rebel and refuse openness as well as
understanding among the nations in
Europe,
for example,
far right parties are spreading
uncertainty.
This is Le Pen in France.
There's violence is in the Netherlands
as hoffer in Austria.
Yeah.
These are all good examples of a new
wave of politics that is also affecting
countries like Finland,
Denmark,
Germany,
and Hungary,
among others.
Further,
it is also partly responsible for the
brexit victory in the United States.
It is a movement that is taking
advantage of fear despite the fact that
we are living in societies that are
becoming safer and safer.
As you well know,
these ideas are not something that is
exclusive to Europe.
Donald Trump won the US election and he
has spoken about his views which are
clearly contrary to globalization and
immigration.
At this point,
the best question we can ask is,
are there any developed countries left
that still believe in open borders and
the globalization?
Well,
the answer to that question is yes,
there are,
and then the video today we're going to
be looking at one of the most
significance of those countries.
Cannabis openness.
Yeah.
Two Thousand and 16 alone.
Canada admitted to its country more than
300,000
immigrants.
It's close to one percent of Canada's
total population.
Further,
this is a greater proportion than any
other developed country and do note here
that this is nothing new.
This is something that's been going on
for two decades,
is a result of this,
is that today,
one in every five Canadians was born
abroad.
This is a percentage that is almost
double that of the US and the UK.
Yeah.
Took.
The matter is,
is that this hasn't led to any sort of
national tragedy.
In fact,
quite the opposite,
and Canadians well notice according to
the prestigious and Veronica's
institute's most citizens,
almost 80 percent of them consider
immigration.
To be good for the economy and think
that it is one of the best ways to deal
with some of the issues facing Canada
such as its aging.
If
you really think about it,
it does make sense.
Employment is the country's most
productive assets,
so why would they want to prevent it
from growing in the context of a dynamic
economy?
What's the harm of immigrants who are
willing to work?
We're willing to set up companies and
once you get an education,
it is something that we have.
Visual politic thing is actually pretty
good.
First Year in 2015 just introduced
became Canada's prime minister.
He defeated against all odds.
The conservative at Stephen Harper.
Harper had held the office for almost 10
years.
Since then,
the political agenda has been dominated
by a determination to deepen the
country's pro globalization policies.
Trudeau himself,
a left winger,
has been quite an advocate of promoting
free trade and social mobility.
In his first year,
he signed a free trade agreement with
the European Union and confirmed
Canada's adherence to the TPP.
Although trump's first action in office
was to destroy the TPP,
was going to be the biggest commercial
agreements in history in just the year
Canada has built up free trade
agreements with nearly 60 percent of the
global economy.
Further Trudeau wants to expand this and
increased trade with China.
We've agreed to launch exploratory talks
towards a potential free trade agreement
between Canada and China.
As the government is doing more of the
same concerning immigration,
they've even set the goal of increasing
the number of immigrants they get 50
percent every single year for my refugee
fleeing Somalia to becoming a member of
parliament in Canada.
I've met as once again a med history
this week after it was named Canada's
Minister of Immigration by Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau in a major
cabinet reshuffle.
Given these principles,
it probably shouldn't surprise you to
learn that Canada is one of the
countries that are most committed to
receiving Syrian refugees.
Canada has received more than 33,000
Syrian refugees since Trudeau took
office in his first year.
Trudeau himself went to Toronto's
airport to welcome the refugees into the
country
migration policy.
Let's hold on a second because
immigration to Canada isn't totally
free,
in fact,
it's not as free as we're visual politic
would like,
but what's really important here is not
whether or whether there are not
excessive administrative difficulties,
so rather than citizens shouldn't
automatically view those who are
immigrating into the country as
criminals,
and this is precisely why Canada is so
successful,
they are a country that takes pride in
looking for additional citizens.
They are not looking for temporary
immigrants since 1967.
Immigration to Canada has been based on
a points system.
This system considers qualifications,
experience professional skills,
and the knowledge of either French or
English in the same way.
The system also gives priority to those
who are needed by Canada's companies.
Canada will lift the Mexican visa
requirement that has restricted travel
to Canada.
This move will make it easier for our
Mexican friends to visit Canada wild
growing our local economies and
strengthening our communities.
The tendency seems to be to make these
procedures easier,
but what is really important is the
social recognition and the integration
of immigrants into the country.
The Canadian bill of rights itself
recognizes the concept of multicultural
patrimony.
There are solid policies to encourage
integration,
which by the way,
don't focus on stripping the immigrants
of their original cultural identity,
but rather see that as an enriching
snowball in Canadian schools.
It is easy to find classes that are
taught in Spanish or Ukrainian and the
results support these policies.
In deed in the last decade,
Canada's growth has been bigger than the
US,
the UK,
and Germany and its citizens in dry,
a very high standard of living.
Now.
Hopefully it might be more clear as to
why Canada's immigration website
collapsed after trump's.
Yeah,
victory.
I understand why the economists has also
had cover pages highlighting Canada's
no,
no.
Of course,
the Canadian model is not perfect boss.
Compared to the new nationalist and
populist tendencies of other countries,
Canada has shown what a desirable
alternative openness can really be.
The key takeaway that we hope this video
really puts across is to try and make
things better in your country rather
than isolated from the rest of the
world.
The latter of which is an argument.
There's many politicians like trump are
defending,
well,
this isn't our opinion here at visual
politic and now we would love to know
yours.
Do you think immigration causes as many
problems as people claim?
Would you like to live in a culturally
diverse country like Canada?
Let us know in the comments below.
Also,
if you enjoy this video,
please do give it a like and also
subscribe to our channel.
Click on the icon on the screen now for
brand new videos every Monday and
Thursday,
and as always,
I'll see you then.